foreign
's prime minister fumio kishida about to
give a speech
and then this
a man wrestled to the ground
expected of throwing an explosive device
towards the crowd
seconds later
in the middle of the melee
chaos and confusion
[Applause]
no one is injured prime minister kashida
unharmed
[Music]
[Applause]
but the crowd clearly shaken as this
local election event at a port in
wakayama turned into something else
entirely
the police are investigating the
suspect's identity and motive
elections are the foundation of
democracy and violence like this cannot
be tolerated during elections I also
instructed the National Police agency to
ensure a thorough protection of
dignitaries
[Music]
then there's the timing
just over nine months since Japan's
former prime minister Shinzo Abe was
assassinated at an election rally in the
city of Nara
shot fired from behind struck our Bay in
the back and the neck
shocking the country forcing tougher gun
controls and Tighter security for its
top leaders
striking similarities between both
attacks and a growing sense of unease it
created a great deal of panic among the
people who had been gathered there the
Prime Minister himself was quickly put
was taken away by Security Services and
just over an hour later he was actually
giving another Street speech nearby so
it hasn't really disrupted uh his
schedule but it's certainly shaken the
nation and reminded a lot of people of
what happened last year
no motive yet for this latest explosion
that people are asking why now and why
again
Nicole Johnston Sky News